un après midi par semaine le vendredi
c'est une petite affaire qui occupe sa
retraite un peu qui le passionne
beaucoup et qui satisfait pleinement son
engagement citoyen la ruche qui dit oui
drôle de nom pour une drôle d'épicerie
de vente presque direct il suffit d'un
garage et d'un ordinateur
c'est simplement pour avoir la
possibilité nous mêmes mais aussi pour
tous les gens que ça intéresse de manger
sainement des produits qui sont pas
toxiques comme ceux qu'on trouve dans
l'agro industrie qui est qui alimente la
grosse distribution très souvent aucun
producteur de mes 25 producteurs environ
que j'ai sélectionné en allant les voir
neta plus de d'une heure de route au
maximum deux shows et c'est lui le
producteur qui fixe son prix le site de
la ruche prélève une commission de ses
ennemis % dont la moitié pour
l'animateur et son modeste business a
pas du tout pas du tout parce que sinon
on ferait faillite ou de suite
non pas du tout mais c'est presque du
militantisme la société de consommation
n'a qu'à bien se tenir
au nom du bien produire et du bien
manger il n'y aura bientôt plus que des
philanthropes pour nous nourrir
elles ont poussé dans le paysage ces
dernières années les petites entreprises
surfant sur la vague du produit fermier
la gourmande normande est de celles-là
sorte de fédération de bons offices qui
assure ne pas courir après des bénéfices
et affirme s'inscrire pleinement dans
ses circuits économies que l'on appelle
circulaire ou collaboratif on est
collaboratif dans ce sens que nous avons
nous avons des producteurs qui vient
vers nous on a au début c'est in your
quitte à aller vers les producteurs pour
demander s'ils pouvaient nous fournissez
et puis en général on a eu la chance que
il y avait pas mal de petits pois
docteur également qu'il cherchait notre
système
une aubaine pour un éleveur laitier que
ce circuit qui lui achète un litre de
lait frais 88 centimes pour le facturer
un euro 0,5
chez des clients livrés visiblement
satisfait
les grandes surfaces sont ce genre de
choses mais il n'y a pas la qualité
donc oui c'est le service le palais et
la formule la plus solidaire la plus
historique d'ailleurs c'est la map
elle a été inventée pour les petits
producteurs amap ça veut dire
association pour le maintien de
l'agriculture paysanne celle de gouvy à
trois ans et demi
elle s'appelle les paniers de la lèze on
s'y retrouve le mardi soir entre
bénévoles producteurs et consommateurs
courent c'est de l'afp chloé la jeune
maraîchère à son exploitation à une
dizaine de kilomètres là et la préparer
26 paniers pour ses abonnés ils ont de
légumes à 20% moins cher que s'il est
sûre l'état le marché on les remercie de
leur fidélité en fait familles
s'engagent pour pour une période qu'ils
choisissent pas leurs légumes et en
contrepartie ils ont
1 % de remise quoi il paye à la fin du
mois pour tout le mois d'après la map
ça crée du lien de la confiance ça leur
a aussi permis de pouvoir s'installer
afin d'avoir un prêt bancaire aussi
intéressant de savoir que c'est un peu
grâce à mikel qu'elles vivent de leur
métier
après plus d'un demi-siècle
d'agriculture intensive et d'hyper
concentration on préfère se retrouver
ici que sur le faux marbres et sous les
néons de la grande distribution dans une
économie plus sociale plus solidaire
collaborative
c'est le commerce équitable près de chez
soi
numéro 8